bild luca bei der lieben freunde wenn
ihr meinen blick in den kalender werft
werde das morgen tatsächlich die erste
april ist der erste april steht für spaß
scherze und schabernack
welcher mensch unter 70 benutzt das wort
schabernack ich war dementsprechend mal
ein bisschen auf tik tok unterwegs und
habe nach apples springs geschaut und
ich wurde auch fündig denn was denn ich
wurde fündig also wörter zu bringen
[Musik]
das hat wirklich so die sache womit man
mich damals in jungen jahren nur aus dem
zimmer hätte holen können
wir reden nicht aber mein deutsch heute
compuware
ich habe schon mal so ein video gemacht
über apples bringt sich glaub ich hab
sogar schon zwei videos dazu gemacht
immer am ersten april des jeweiligen
jahres und diese hier
diese logischerweise aus dem letzten
jahr deswegen kann es sein dass ich so
ein ähnliches schon mal hat habe ich
fand den schrei von ihm einfach viel zu
witzig lasst mich das ganz kurz
zusammenfassen
die eltern haben die kinder geprägt von
wegen hey unser auto hat keinen sprit
mehr wir halten jetzt an und müssen
laufen sehr für die kinder ausgesetzt
und sind weggefahren
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das vielleicht
komisch klingen wenn ich das jetzt sage
euch hat das trotzdem voll gern gegessen
ich bin ich auch im krieg aber ich finde
auch immer so schwämme sehen richtig
appetit sich auch
[Musik]
stellt euch mal vor irgend jemanden
eurem freundeskreis bringt euch einfach
seit seiner geburt und dann irgendwann
so nach 15 jahren löste das da so auf
wie krank wer das mein gott sie bringt
ihren freund oder mann keine ahnung
einfach damit dass sie sagt dass ihre
fruchtblase geplatzt ist und dass das
baby kommt um zwölf uhr nachts ich wäre
so im dreieck kekse mit zwiebeln tabasco
mayonnaise und salz also mädels wenn das
euer erster apple fools day was
definitiv also der bank hat richtig gut
funktioniert
oh mein gott die armen kinder alter
stellt euch mal vor eure eltern sagen
euch einfach ja die ferien wurden schon
einen tag früher beendet hier schaut mal
fällt gegen die sonne news artikel oder
so es geht ja voll stellen und dann
stehst du der montags morgens um 7 uhr
30 vor dem auto 113 kommt rein aber ich
war ich hätte meine sachen gepackt wie
rausgezogen bruder
ich fühl dich bei dem nächsten
aprilscherz den ich euch jetzt gleich
anwenden werde sind alle eingeweihten
bis auf das kleine mädchen und dieses
kleine mädchen besitzt ein ipad welches
so tun die jungs zumindest sie kaputt
machen dann nehmen sie es von einem
treppengeländer vorsprung runter schweiz
auf dem boden allerdings ist das ein
kaputtes ipad was sie schon vor im
internet bestellt haben also seht
einfach selbst wie das mädchen reagiert
[Musik]
und die du ich finds halt echt so
ekelhaft wie dramatisch materialistisch
die heutige jugend ist werde ich alt
da war alles besser
ich habe gerade überlegt wie es wäre
wenn ich das bei meinen eltern machen
würde aber ich glaube die wird noch
etwas sagen warum denn jetzt schon
[Musik]
wen willst du verarschen mann du hast
das geschieht in deinem schnittprogramm
und hat es aber in dem richtigen video
den grünen umhang um das heißt der typ
hatte ich die ganze zeit gesehen wurde
[Musik]
also klar den pranken jeder so du nimmst
irgendwelche are links daneben und
fußball als ob du im jahre abrasiert
trotzdem hat auch solche leute die dann
kommentieren wer versteht das alles ich
verstehe dass diese ticker kommentare
was so los was ich mich bei diesem video
aber einfach frage ist was versteht ihr
am ende wenn ich verstehe dass da peking
mitteilte okay machen wir weiter mit dem
nächsten tik tok april fool's day break
meine lieben freunde und zwar besteht
dieser frank aus zwei zwillingen zwei
mädels und die eine von denen hat einen
freund und die tauschen die rollen und
guckt ob der freund das merkt
[Musik]
b
also jetzt bei der pranke komplett
beiseite was ist das für eine kranke
wohnung gewesen
hallo
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der trainer dann gerufen die wollen ihre
schauspieler zurück
[Musik]
oder kommt direkt wieder anrufe ein
das war's mit meinem heutigen video
weiter lieben freunde wenn euch diese
app refrains gefallen haben das kann
einen download im video abonniert nur
ein kanal falls doch keiner der lucio
sein und das morgige neue minecraft
video nicht verpassen wollt kommt
nämlich um 20 uhr und falls ihr noch
inspiration braucht für den morgigen
ersten april und für euren aprilscherz
ich glaube ich habe noch nie ein
aprilscherz geplant ist auch ein ganz
eigener schlagmänner die so etwas planen
naja wenn ihr auf jeden fall inspiration
braucht man hier erwartet den clip und
ich meine komplette heute
[Musik]